stream fails never got one never will
get one right Kim that's right never
never wait you yeah that's right you've
never gotten any bad and perfect that's
what I'm talking about let's just watch
other people suffer okay yes and pretend
we don't
parents swears where I was
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
real dude thanks to all of you
was that real do you see a ghost just
this old man just sitting there watching
TV he's why is he naked he's in this
house why can't he be naked what is
wrong with America
yo bro are you real
you're American so you this is normal
for you is that what you're saying no
no no it's not
I like the comments saying San Diego is
the prettiest City wow it's so pretty
like American cities are trash what are
they talking about they're so dirty oh
man
you [ __ ]
I got a flashlight looking at the window
he's like what's up what's going on out
there who's out there it's creepy they
screaming yo man I'm watching this
stream right now he was watching the
stream got naked and was he knew that
was gonna happen hopefully he doesn't
know what the stream is because filming
into his house you know I'm sure that's
legal liability right there is it really
well you can't just go and like stick
cameras in people's windows that's
what's what's with all these goddamn
Windows like straight on a busy street
some place in front of it some [ __ ]
trying to see old naked people put some
blinds up Man Zero followers and like
you know this whole thing
um so good I got fused um what are you
doing
that's his mom is that what he said Mom
yeah what the [ __ ] Mom I'm hoping
Yu-Gi-Oh cards what are you doing I
don't know the way that's framed I feel
like it's on purpose honestly yeah yeah
yeah it's the same oh
oh oh oh I'm so surprised oh what do you
Mom
I swear to God stream is like the only
place where you can like have these
moments
or get banned and it's a good thing you
know right you're on YouTube oh no oh no
my video yeah I'm getting Adrians yeah
am I out of the algorithm am I out of
the loop what's going on there I swear
ever since my mom walked in good job
good job streamer drama baby yes we love
it yeah it's a weird system it doesn't
they've stuck with it but it doesn't
seem to work at all yeah streamers like
baiting the band all the time like oh
yeah oh I got banned oh gosh no I'm
gonna get banned this is so bad come
back bigger than ever yeah yeah I would
love a vacation a paid vacation YouTube
come on
oh no they're Swedish oh no Swedish
people will never do these
idiot he's got the hat on and everything
you don't deserve that hat look how much
water there is what are you doing
you can't operate like Vehicles when
you're streaming I thought like period
oh
maybe maybe she's the one in the end I
don't know either way
is it the same word in no it's Kroner
why is it Swedish they're not Swedish
they're probably Norwegian of course of
course it all makes sense now how could
they disappoint you in this way yeah
they would never do that you know I used
to be a harbor Captain Ken oh yeah
what did that what did you do with that
job
I went out to boats and I said hello go
over here oh follow me he told him where
to park gotcha yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is like a ballet for boats
basically but it's called Harbor Captain
it sounds real cool though you've been
telling me you were a harbor captain
forever and at first I was like oh wow
that's
sounds like a cool title and you were
like what 16 or something wow you must
really know how to sail I I was a legend
yeah
I know how to say them he was a legend
you know how to say oh you're yeah Pro
seller yeah I won a competition really
yeah I got a cup got a cup yeah I got
what a cup
gosh that's gonna be like gonna be more
proud of that like your YouTube 100
subscribers I don't even have those
anymore but I do have that little cups
left
oh
[Music]
fall on your face she's pretty high
[Music]
we've broken our neck dude that was that
was a pretty big ball I was like
oh why am I laughing can I laugh
all right guys
it's okay what would be nice about this
new rig
you already know what's gonna happen
oh I feel bad
[Music]
think about
is that a shirt and a shirt it's a shirt
on a shirt like I laughed again
it didn't cross a little bit
yeah that must be expensive god with the
tempered glass yeah it's supposed to be
tough too supposed to be strong not that
one I have a hat it's in my bag
you like my hair I dyed it is what
living in Sweden looks like
God damn that's not how I remember it if
you had one of those jackets that
attract the snow you're a loser okay I'm
just gonna say it the the snow sticks
too you're a loser yeah yeah what the
[ __ ] are you doing get a proper jacket
this guy behind him is gonna let him
know okay yeah exactly that's the that's
how you do it the guy behind him knows
that he's done Sweden is really letting
me down in this video cam they're lost
without you you're gonna have to go back
to the motherland one day and
lead them back guys you need jacket that
repels the water
you need it proper jacket watch where
you're going when you're sailing yes
they need to go to the bathroom use the
shower hey stop it no
that's not cool
anyways would you rather be smart and
beautiful or dumb and ugly dumb and ugly
no wait smart and beautiful like I
didn't understand the question
same I would fix what is it
beautiful smart that's beautiful
I want all of it dumb and ugly yeah
look I can't make fun of these streamers
man like I mean we both of us dropped
out of freaking school to do YouTube so
can act like I'm a genius or they would
teach you how to answer that question in
school what was that of the old game on
like the the DS like you did uh the
frontal lobe exercises mind something
yeah yeah if I only exercise my brain
more I could remember yes yes brain
exercise we could have went to school
longer and got more exercise in with our
our brains do you think they actually
work do you think you get a bigger brain
I don't think your brain gets bigger but
they do say that your brain is much like
a muscle if you don't use it then it
gets lazy and doesn't work good yeah
that makes sense yeah I gotta use it
which some people know yeah some people
oh yeah this guy's screaming can you
notice it let's get this
[Applause]
selfish
of course he is I didn't even know where
he that guy was incredible wow
how does he know where everyone is how
are cheetahs so [ __ ] stupid how do
you mess that up
like damn it this happens all the time
too do they have the freaking the Aimbot
on as well that just aims for him he
doesn't have to like no I think at least
but look at this guy
through the wall he's just like should I
shoot him should I shoot him yeah
oh wow I know wow dude you know I told
you that play like the Grand Theft Auto
role play in my free time sometimes
um you didn't have any
um you didn't have a reticle or anything
you didn't have a diet for when you
shoot
yeah there's a guy streaming he's like
streaming to everyone and he speaks to
get into a fight he's like oh hang on a
second and he goes and like pulls up his
like
his overlay for being able to have a DOT
on his screen in front of everyone is
like all right all right cool let's go
oh no no wait
but you can do that on a lot of this
place you know yeah exactly that's cut
they eventually added it uh yeah but
yeah people yeah I would do I would do
that what the [ __ ] that's hard where
that's not cheating that's hardware
acceleration it's the hardware Advantage
no I'm I'm good I can turn on my yeah
yeah you can turn on my my DOT on my
screen I would 100 that's okay this none
this is not this is lame before we
continue quick word from sponsor are you
control of your internet experience well
take control today with nordvpn check
out nordvpn.com pdf5 for the greatest
VPN of all time oh look at all these
trash vpns So Glorious
nordvpn actually care about your
security and they have a cyber security
awareness campaign for example lesson
one this one's for free if you connect
to a public Wi-Fi anyone could be
hosting that anyone can go to Starbucks
and set up a free cafe Wi-Fi you want to
join oh got all your [ __ ] always use the
VPN when connecting to public Wi-Fi rule
number one everyone knows this for only
a couple bucks a month you can protect
yourself and of course nordvpn the
greatest VPN has another level of
security with threat protection you
don't even have to connect to a VPN to
use it it adds another layer protects
your downloads protects from malware
malicious trackers intrusive ads all
that stuff bang bang boom nerd VPN ganji
protected
but of course one of the greatest things
that I use for VPN is I have it on my TV
if I want to watch any streaming service
from another country which since I'm in
Japan right now is very very useful one
click connects super fast and you can
watch whatever you want it's just one of
those things that is always nice to have
and right now if you sign up with the
link in the description nordvpn.com
PewDiePie for a two-year deal you get
additional four months for free it's an
incredible offer I highly recommend it
you won't regret it you will only miss
it and curse it if you don't have it
when you want it I use it every single
day thank you nordvpn for sponsoring
this video let's keep watching
foreign
[Laughter]
that's stream straight sniping down
right
that's exactly what he's doing
this is some weird Korean place okay I
got the tape on the wall it's fine yeah
it looks nice
isn't that kind of the thing like street
food kind of like that I never did yeah
I think it's like I remember going to
L.A and they'd be like this is the best
place you'll ever be yeah and it looks
like you walk in and you're here and
you're like
the guy outside with a knife is like
licking it looking at the window through
you're like oh God what a great
experience oh wow thanks for taking me
you know how they say like the bathroom
is how the kitchen is yeah yeah it's not
clean I wish I never knew that because
whenever I like I have my meal I'm like
that's pretty good I gotta go to the
bathroom and then I look at the bathroom
like oh God oh God oh did you see the uh
the video about the guy who uses like
the little air dryers and like use like
a little petri dish to see if uh
bacteria grows after he blows them on
them wait say that again the little hand
the air dryers like you put your hand
under it blows air to dry your hands
yeah a guy like took like little dishes
like a little scientific little Petri
dishes or whatever and got it to blow on
it oh if it had bacteria on it and let
the bacteria grow yeah it was pretty uh
oh no [ __ ] way yeah
dry your hands from now on
I mean it's just a mat because you know
toilet seats right they're functional
you put toilet seats down when you flush
so like all your poop water doesn't fly
throughout the whole room
in public toilets and stuff like that
that's just fine all over the place and
then it sucked me I never I never close
am I supposed to close
have you ever like did the vaccine
MythBusters where they like they had
they had I thought that was inconclusive
yeah I saw it but what no they like they
tested like the toothbrush and found
like particles oh my God I gotta close
and it serves a purpose it's just oh my
hair looks oh
well I'm 32 years old and I just learned
something today Kim thank you so much I
will from now on click the button to
close you got a button that closes it
yeah I'm not I'm not gonna touch that
who do you think I am
oh my God that's the most annoying [ __ ]
sometimes I cut my toenails and I'm
leaned over my foot on the toilet you
cut your toenail from the toilet okay
yeah yes yeah sorry but then it closes
automatically on my head I'm like God
damn it on your head yeah cause I lean
forward yeah you must be like down there
I'm in there yeah
yeah every time it hits me I'm like I
don't have enough time I need more time
toilet God damn and it's actually at
first I thought it was really cool how
it open on its own but now because I
have to go past it all the time
it just opens up like dude I'm not
talking to you right now hey bro go away
God shut up
please not end stream
it's gonna be in stream
well you put it there come on
I feel like he like it moves a little
bit I wonder if he pushed it with his
hand behind there to In The Stream he's
like oh no I don't want to stop
screaming please
get out of here it's been 12 hours I'm
tired
laughs
tada
I told you you should trust me chat but
this one's personal
oh but this one actually personal
thank God you played yourself got him
you guys I hear the music do you guys I
hear the music
divide equals crack that was my
appreciation
oh what are you doing
you put sparkling water in his G fuel
that's what's wrong that's forbidden you
can't trust sparkling water that's why I
hate sparkling water it's the devil you
can't trust it why would you shake it
too come on the gas has got to go
somewhere that's a good mantra for life
oh my God
oh God Jesus oh no
it happens we've all been there
context is glass I felt okay I think I
got that okay
slow motion so we can see what happened
there
what just happened kid I don't get it
what happened
context he shook his G Fuel and it had
sparkly water inside and the carbon
dioxide made the gases expand and he
lost his eye he lost his glass eye
oh thank you so much
I love that reaction ew I'm sorry
shaming him meat head shaming him how
could she don't turn the camera all
around Felix
oh my [ __ ] god dude
[Laughter]
oh the drinks I'm like okay but the
uneven food that's all that's just bad
dude oh God he said it's not that bad
what what
we got Subway Starbucks
McDonald's we got the whole Spiel what
what do you think you're streaming all
little like 24 7. you just just throw
your bag over there in the pile
I've reacted to hoarder videos that look
a lot like this
reminds me there was a famous one I love
the title too multi-millionaire
streaming
gold the man who who gives all this life
advice and just
thanks to everyone
you need to watch uh Peterson clean your
room he's watching this I don't know
like it makes me anxious but also a
little sad
it's uh like thinking about cleaning
this up just makes me angry I don't want
to do it yeah but I want to do it
but this is so dirty that if you just
like
damn just shove it all throw it off yeah
it doesn't even matter like you don't
have to be careful a giant drum from the
freaking hardware store and just throw
it all in it yeah man yeah yeah
how does your desk look like him uh I
mean I got a DND book right here I got
two well one empty can of Coke and one's
halfway and the other one is in the
glass the rest of us in the glass uh I
got an air conditioner remote a pen
that's broken oh it's not like this
level man so you got like us who we do
videos I feel like when we're recording
videos we like put more into it in the
moment like we go hard for like 30
minutes I'm like ah you know are we
usually yeah and then we're like all
right let's clean all this [ __ ] not so
much anymore but we used to like like
really get into it while we're making
the videos but when you're streaming you
sit there and you're kind of doing your
thing but you have to do it for like so
long
right that's a lot of hours that goes
into it but even the vent right there is
freaking awesome
I don't know if there's something wrong
with me but if I even see like a smudge
on the wall my brain is just like
have to clean it I can't do anything my
man he's got he's got the A1 sauce on
there The Mug Root Beer that's what I'm
talking about the the Black Bottle like
right there that's the A1 oh you know
that body it doesn't even show it I ate
one sauce yeah I love the World of
Warcraft there's some Sweet Baby Ray's
on there somewhere too I was down there
by the feet oh man I'm sure after this
there's so much to take in today I'm
sure after this picture like all this
[ __ ] food down there I'm sure after
this picture came out it got cleaned up
you know I'm sure it's not like this
anymore right yeah yeah suddenly I feel
pretty good in my face yeah yeah it's
pretty clean here
speaking of streaming for a long time
you go to sleep
it's a good content oh oh he's done
how the [ __ ] do you do that
they have sleep streams nowadays they
used to be against the rules to fall
asleep on the stream but now you can
just sleep while you want why was it
against the rules uh it was something
about leaving your stream unattended
like it just being there and like you
know chat with me it'll do whatever
whatever happens you're like no one's
controlling it okay now you can sleep
all you want you know it's all good you
can just straight sleep all right yeah
you sleep on stream people people do it
they do like their big subathons where
like everyone who subscribes adds more
time to a timer and you know it gets
like 24 hours I'm like okay I gotta I'm
going to sleep so just go to sleep and
leave this one you gotta slain all right
well what if people want out of watching
it that's the that's the question right
I think they're gonna like say something
bad in their sleep or something but
maybe it's that the fear of missing out
you're like I gotta watch what are they
gonna do are they gonna like he moved
all right awesome Graphics uh of course
you at home were able to watch these top
level
talented individuals do what they do
best you can catching no I didn't see
what happened watch it one more time
um her awesome Graphics uh of course you
at home were able to watch these top
level
talented individuals
yeah you guys should be honest with
yourself you know you see it walk by and
you just gotta be like
he did what he had to do I get it oh
yeah nice oh yeah you like that is that
the guy from stranger things
the dad
back it up
oh yeah
oh yeah let's fight back
are you streaming oh I'm so sorry but I
happen to be shaking my booty here sorry
for your streamer entitled let's take
this
it seems fun to stream IRL but then also
it just seems like such a bad idea it's
so annoying to like everybody else that
yeah I I've seen a couple here in Japan
as well as soon as I see one I'm like
I'm going over here all right because
they recognize you they're gonna be like
right it's scary yeah the worst film me
it could be on the stream fail because
right you know where that would happen
it's not gonna happen well if you know
this video smash like subscribe check
out Ken's Channel as well and I'll see
you next time